I mean it wasn't just a popular movie it
was just a ridiculously explosive pop
culture moment right I mean at one point
someone said stick your head in the
theatres and when I've seen it they said
no no you can't believe because there's
about three or four months into the run
and I I stuck my head in and there were
beach balls being going around but it
was more like a party you know where
they'd are they they they were it was
almost like Rocky Horror they knew the
answer back they had their favorite
moments I mean it was astonishing to me
enough I don't know how they knew before
to give you an example the day that it
opened which was May 25th of 77 they
were we were working on the sound mix
for the the 70 millimeter prints were
already in the theaters but they were
working on the sound for the 35
millimeter prints and I said the car
picked me up and I said can you go buy
Grauman's Chinese because the movies
playing and nobody could decide on a
poster there was big arguments over what
would convey what this movie was about
was it heavy and deep and you know
intellectual like 2001 or was you know
Little Rascals in outer space I mean you
know there was a great to and fro in
terms of how to promote it and the
upshot is that there was no agreement we
didn't get a poster until I don't know I
don't want probably fans that know
better than me but certainly not by
opening day and I don't know whether it
took a week or a month before eventually
they I think they came up with a
Hildebrandt poster with a you know the
the guy that looked like Luke's you know
uncle you know with a fantastic physique
and six foot four you know but again so
there was that back and forth about how
to promote it so we drove by the theater
and to my amazement there were lines
around the block and I couldn't figure
out how about could be there was a
trailer that was playing care
and I stuck art ed we said to the guy
you know it's in Westwood I said we're
in this movie that's coming out I mean
it's just it's kind of a weird spin we
said it's called Star Wars ium we heard
you're showing the trailer we just want
to see the trailer we don't want to have
to bother anybody and we don't really
want to you let us go in you know I
didn't idea sore anything I said go
ahead so we stuck our head I still
remember too because we've never seen
any footage well the you know the stuff
we 80-yard and so forth we'd seen
footage I take that back
but my point is you know in terms of
effects and all of this and I don't know
if you remember this somewhere in space
intercut lifted intercut with this slow
sort of message and they come to the end
of the message you know more fast
cutting of you know assault on the Death
Star and shots of the wookie with his
headphones which is you know you know
just showing that to an audience with no
sort of out explenation honestly in 77
yeah where people just aren't used to
see him when they say science fiction
they go oh is it like 2001 yeah rather
than try and explain it you know I mean
there was planning to the a there's
certain things like if you could sort of
wedge in there but even that's not a
good example because they don't think of
it really as a space movie it's also it
was the action element like you know
like there was such an action element to
it
2001 great movie not a lot of action a
lot action not a lot of laughs right so
although the computer turning on the
human I mean that appealed to me no but
it finished this particular story we see
this trailer so you know someone's face
could all be happening and then it says
a billion light years in the making and
it's coming to your galaxy this summer
and there's a huge explosion and
somebody called out from the back of the
theater yeah and it's coming to
late-night TV about a week after that
[Laughter]
Vica and caring I just look to each
other like it was funny he got a really
good laugh one of those you know
audience but yeah I wish you could
attract that guy down a month later
you're like well based on TV is all
based on what based on what he had just
seen there was no way in his mind that
could have been a successful movie was
just too goofy and they didn't really I
don't think they really singled out Sir
Alec you know which is on a major
component just in its credibility and
getting financing and so forth you know
a technique they later used with Marlon
Brando and Superman to give it sort of a
gravitas that it wouldn't ordinarily
have had with mostly unknowns are all
unknowns but again I mean I don't know
how these people some people say well
the reason there was lines around the
block on the very first day is there's a
core audience of people that will go see
fantasy and science fiction films no
matter what but like I say I mean I
don't remember any ads on Saturday Night
Live I certainly don't remember any ads
on TV there might have been a newspaper
ad but there were no posters and they
they did have stapled up Lobby cards but
like I say it was one of those things
that it's always because at the time I
remember saying this thing will be
popular I think it'll be as popular as
the original plan of the ape so I was
one of the people that said I really
think it says all the elements I said
even if it doesn't do it really well at
the box office it's gonna be a cult
movie meaning college kids are gonna
come to midnight screenings and love it
because of the humor because the robots
were so funny and the you know and the
cynicism of a han Solo character and the
gravitas of Sir Alec and just all of it
I mean it's it I said it's more a fairy
tale than it is traditional science
fiction we got a farm boy and a wizard
and a pirate and you know in a princess
it really seems to me that it has a
great a chance for crossover appeal
because they know they do to all these
studies and they said well women don't
like science fiction in fact they wanted
to take the
word Wars out of the title twentieth
century-fox they had a name the movie
contest while we were shooting it at the
on the bulletin board if you can come up
with a name that was better than Star
Wars you know cuz they you know they had
all these focus groups that say you know
well thirty percent of people that
polled with that title think it's a
behind the scenes look at the Elizabeth
Taylor Richard Burton marriage seriously
and okay I know I kept thinking well
what would be a better title because the
first time I ever read a script it was
called let's see The Adventures of Luke
Skywalker has taken from the Journal of
the Wills saga number one the Star Wars
that was the title surprise they didn't
stick with that long well is there a
longer title really trying but the long
and the short of it was nobody who came
up with a title that because a lot of
people tried I tried I can't remember
what I came up with but and nobody
actually ever came up with the title
they liked better than that but that was
the story all over I mean I remember
George went to McDonald's he got turned
down so we went to Burger we got Burger
King and he went to Mattel Toys who got
turned down so we got Kenner who we were
everybody's second choice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]